>> Laura: THE DEMOCRAT BITTER
BUNCH.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
[BEEP]
>> ANGRY WOMEN GETS THINGS DONE.
WE NEED TO GET THINGS DONE.
>> Laura: WELL THEY'RE GREAT AT
ANGER AND FURRY.
THINK ABOUT WHAT DEMOCRATS AND
THE SUPPORTERS ON THE STREETS
ARE NOT CELEBRATING.
A RECORD STOCK MARKET ACROSS ALL
THREE INDUSTRIES.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
RECORD CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
AND RECORD GAINS FOR FEMALE
BLACK ENTREPRENEURS.
I COULD GO ON AND ON.
IN OTHER WORDS THE HAPPIER YOU R
THE GRUMPIER YOU GET.
TRUMP EASY ECONOMY AND
DEREGULATORY MOVES HAVE MADE IT
EASIER FOR BUSINESSES TO GROW.
IT PUTS MORE MONEY IN THE
POCKETS OF HARD WORKING
AMERICANS LIKE YOU.
DEMOCRATS FRANKLY ARE FINE WITH
YOU BEING MISERABLE, WHY?
THEY WANT TO CONTROL YOU.
THEY ARE A BROKEN DOWN PARTY
RUNNING BROKEN CITIES.
DO YOU WANT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
TO BE RUN LIKE CHICAGO OR L.A.?
WHERE THERE ARE A LOT OF POOR
PEOPLE AND A LOT OF RICH PEOPLE
AND A TINY MIDDLE CLASS
SLINKING?
MISERABLE CONDITIONS,
HOMELESSNESS AND DESPAIR.
YES REPUBLICANS WERE DEPRESSED
DURING THE OBAMA YEARS.
WE SAW OUR TREASURED
INSTITUTIONS UNDER ASSAULT.
WE WERE HOPEFUL AND WANTED TO
SEE THINGS BETTER.
I AM THINKING DEMOCRATS ENJOY
BEING MISERABLE UNLESS THEY'RE
BOSSING US AROUND.
CALL THEM THE UNHAPPY PARTY.
THEY'RE UNHAPPY WITH EACH OTHER
THEY'RE UNHAPPY WITH AMERICA'S
FOUNDING, OUR CULTURE, OUR
TRADITIONS, OUR HISTORICAL
FIGURES, ALMOST OUR ENTIRE
AMERICAN STORY.
REMEMBER HOW BACK IN 2016 THE
MEDIA TALKED ABOUT HOW ANGRY
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WERE.
>> THE ANGER SHOWS IN THEIR
FACES THEY'RE NOT HAPPY PEOPLE.
>> THE CROWDS HE DRAWS THEY'RE
ALL WHITE AND THEY'RE SCARED.
THEY'RE VERY ANGRY.
>> THEY'RE VERY LOYAL.
THEY'RE LIKE DONALD TRUMP VERY
ANGRY.
>> Laura: LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATS
TODAY.
THEY NEVER LOOK LIKE THEY'RE IN
A GOOD MOOD.
THEY'RE ALWAYS COMPLAINING AND
NEVER WANT TO WORK WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON ANY ISSUE.
TRUMP IS GOING TO SPEND THE NEXT
YEAR PLUS GOING TOWN TO TOWN
SPEAKING  ABOUT THE AMERICAN
RENEWAL THAT HIS POLICIES HAVE
HELPED SPARK.
NOW SURE HE WILL HIT THE
DEMOCRATIC FIELD REALLY HARD
TOO.
I THINK THIS CAMPAIGN IS MOSTLY
GOING BETWEEN TWO COMPETING
VISIONS OF AMERICA.
ONE FAIRLY DARK.
ONE LET'S KEEP THE GOOD TIMES
GOING.
DO YOU TRUST BIDEN, WARREN OR
HARRIS TO SPEND YOUR MONEY AND
SET YOUR FAMILY'S PRIORITIES?
WHEN AMERICANS ARE AT EACH
OTHERS THROATS DEMOCRATS ARE
HAPPIEST THAT IS WHEN AMERICANS,
THEY HOPE, WILL WANT GOVERNMENT
TO STEP IN AND DECIDE EVERYTHING
FOR US.
PROTECT US FROM EACH OTHER
RADICAL THINKING SAL OLINSKY SAW
THIS.
HIS TENTH RULE, RULE OF
RADICALS.
>> Laura: TODAYS THOSE WHO ARE
ON THE STREETS ARE ANGRY
AULINSKYITES LOOKING TO PROMOTE
CONFLICT AND EVEN A CIVIL WAR.
THESE MASS MORE ONS
THESE MASS MORONONS
THESE MASS MORONSNS
THESE MASS MORONS THINK THIS
WILL BRING A JUST SOCIETY.
IT WOULD RESULT IN LESS FREEDOM,
MORE POVERTY WITH A SMALL GROUP
OF RICH PEOPLE RUNNING THE SHOW.